the function f is defined over the real
numbers
this table gives select values of f we
have our table here for any for these x
values it gives the corresponding f of x
what is a reasonable estimate for the
limit of f x as x approaches one
from the left so pause this videos and
see if you can figure it out on your own
all right now let's work through this
together so the important the first
thing that is really important to
realize is when you see this x
approaches one and you see this little
negative superscript here this does not
mean approaching negative one so this
does not mean negative one sometimes
your brain just sees a one and that
little negative sign there you're like
oh this must be a weird way of writing
negative 1 or you don't even think about
it but it's not saying that it's saying
this is saying let me put a little arrow
here this is the limit
of f of x
as x
approaches 1 from the left
from
the left
so
from the left how do we know that well
that's what that little negative tells
us it tells us we're approaching 1 from
values less than one if we're
approaching one from the right from
values greater than one that would be a
positive sign right over there
so let's think about it we want the
limit as x approaches one from the left
and lucky for us on this table we have
some values of x approaching 1 from the
left 0.9 that which is already pretty
close to 1 then we get even closer to 1
from the left notice these are all less
than 1 but they're getting closer and
closer to 1. and so what we really want
to look at is the val what does f of x
approach as x is getting closer and
closer let me write it as x is getting
closer and closer to 1 from the left
from the left and a key
realization here is if we're looking if
we're thinking about general limits not
just from one direction then we might
want to look at from the left and from
the right but they're asking us only
from the left so we should only be
looking at these values right over here
in fact we shouldn't even let the value
of f of x at x equal one confuse us
sometimes and often times the limit is
approaching a different value than the
actual then the value of the function at
that point so let's look at this at 0.9
f of x is 2.5 when we get even closer to
1 from the left we go to 2.1 when we get
even closer to 1 from the left we're
getting even closer to 2. so a
reasonable estimate for the limit as x
approaches 1 from the left of f of x it
looks like x
it looks like f of x right over here is
approaching 2. we don't know for sure
that's why they're saying what is a
reasonable estimate it might be
approaching 2.01 or it might be
approaching 1.999
on khan academy these will often be
multiple choice questions so you have to
pick them the most reasonable one it
would not be fair if they gave a 1.999
as a choice and 2.01 but if you were
saying hey maybe this is approaching a
whole number then 2 could be a
reasonable estimate right over here
although it doesn't have to be 2 it
could be 2.01258
it might be what it is actually
approaching
so let's try another example here here
it does look like there's a reasonable
estimate for the limit as we approach
this value from the left
so now it says the function f is defined
over the real numbers this table gives
select values of f similar to the last
question what is a reasonable estimate
for the limit as x approaches negative 2
from the left so this is confusing you
see these two negative signs this first
negative sign tells us we're approaching
negative 2. we want to say what happens
when we're approaching negative 2 and
we're going to approach once again from
the left
so lucky for us they have values of x
that are approaching negative 2 from the
left so this is x
approaches negative 2 from the left and
so that is happening right over here
so that's these values
so notice this is negative 2.05 then we
can even close or negative 2.01 then we
get even closer negative
2.002 and these are from the left
because these are values less than
negative 2 but they're getting closer
and closer to negative 2.
and so let's see
when we're a little bit further f of x
is negative 20. we get a little bit
closer it's negative 100 we get even a
little bit closer it goes to negative
500. so it looks it would be reasonable
and we don't know for sure this is just
giving us a few sample points for this
function but if we follow this trend as
we get closer and closer to 2 as we get
closer and closer to negative 2 without
getting there it looks like this is
getting unbounded it looks like it's
becoming infinitely negative and so
technically it looks like
this is i would write this as unbounded
and so if this was a multiple choice
question and technically you would say
this the limit as x approaches negative
2 from the left does not exist
it does
not
exist
if someone asked the other question if
they said what is the limit
as x approaches negative 2
from the right of f of x
well then you would say all right well
here are values approaching negative 2
from the right so this is x approaching
negative 2 from the right
right over here and remember you when
you're looking at a limit sometimes it
might be distracting to look at the
actual value of the function at that
point so you want to think about what is
the value of the function approaching as
your x is approaching that value as x is
approaching in this case negative 2 from
the right so as we're getting closer and
closer to negative 2 from values larger
than negative 2 it looks like f of x is
getting closer and closer to negative
four which is f of negative two but that
actually seems like a reasonable
estimate once again we don't know
absolutely for sure just by sampling
some points but these would this this
would be a reasonable estimate
and in general if you are approaching
different values from the left then from
the right then you would say at that
point the limit of your function does
not exist and we've seen that in other
videos